Alright guys, so here is an example for the silver bullet inter-day bias
Sculpting whatever you want to call it right so first of all we want to determine the
Since we're gonna take our entry on the one minute. We want to determine our 15 minute bias or narrative
So right here we have this external taken out at 330 right
So from here onwards what you want to look for is a free value gap here, right?
So we have this free value gap now going to the one minute time frame
This is gonna be a drawn liquidity, right? So we have to look for a shift in the market structure
And that happens right there and we have this free value gap
So we're gonna get our entry before 4 o'clock, right? So
We get our entry at 354 so we should be good. This is gonna be our draw, right? And if I play this through
You will see that we have hit our take profit level and
If I play through you will see that after price takes up the objective it will just go up
So that is the beauty of using this external internal with your
Every single strategy that I have right it could even either be Asian session could be the 9th area and 8th area open
You have this beautiful tool that you can use right now, okay, and yeah, that's pretty much about it
Let me give you guys one more example. Simply look for a shift in the market structure
as I said before the timings
Is that your entry only must be after in during the kill during the silver bullet hours, okay?
The shift in the market structure can happen anytime as long as that
Liquidity level is still intact the drawn liquidity you can take your entry in that direction after 10 or after 3
So let's move on to the next example